welcome to this video playing me call
kar 1985 Grandmaster from Belarus right
nikita our mayor of professional player
and so on okay so let's see nims oh ok
let's let's try once again the Zurich
subject up from my book one subject III
okay yeah I always had the impression
that III is not particularly dangerous
but okay
yeah I guess be three okay I was
surprised they're low a form but quite
often seems to be an option okay I just
block the queenside yeah his play form
for F form
hmm
yeah interesting if i take
okay I don't need to take and it's not
so much pressure on it I can just play
row create first yeah of course in
general white wants to open up the
position with the bishops while I need
to be a careful with the timing of of
any porn breaks hmm i wonder if i take
this is if this is really bad okay let's
let's do that this check is this good
probably not okay need to protect age
seven so that second I can actually play
that him check I have projected that
white resigns okay now this is bad i'm
not quite sure what he was thinking
though yeah i mean ok now let's its
background chess i'm obviously somewhat
worse here the question is how much it
it's not looking great i I understand a
few if you say that this is a bad
position but it's not easy for why to
make progress our plate but should be
seven protect day for the Queen side is
fries and the only way you can make any
progress advanced kingside pawns why
does better there's no question but it's
not a position that winds itself it's
not so easy okay Bishop h7 was just
donating to a good course but yeah it's
a shame I would have liked to see how to
continue how to others game continues I
don't know probably maybe I shouldn't
take us something yeah it's always it's
always debatable if you should move this
this a pawn in general I in the
in the analysis for my book I found that
a pretty good plan is always c6 but if I
if I know I just want I just want to mix
things this this kind of stuff it's
normally quite good does this 94 idea
let's say boo should be a 94 there's a
typical idea queen who treats and then
um a setup let's say with be six is good
tending night e 6 special be seven maybe
95 it's a very solid position well why
it doesn't have anything special some a
good alternative this is maybe this is a
bit too slow i don't know i'm spending
many many moves on the queenside and
he's just opening opening things up I
don't want to play that this is a
computer move computer suggestion this
is just it's just terrible giving up the
diagonal and the long run white will
manage to to get something going on the
King side so I'm what I want to do is I
keep this porno or take yeah I could I
could play that it's it's not it's not
out of the out of the question something
like that would also allow me to to
regroup regroup the night yeah maybe
this is what I should do if he if he
tries to intensify the pressure here
only five I have other ideas I can can
try that for example yeah it's a complex
position in any case and they are lucky
that he just took the home page seven
thanks for watching